in multiple videos already we have
talked about the three branches of
government at the federal level you have
the legislative branch which is congress
made up of two houses the house of
representatives and the senate you have
the executive branch
with the president at the head of the
executive branch and of course you have
the judicial now what we're going to
focus on in this video is in previous
videos we've talked about that the
executive branch is in charge of running
the government while the legislative
branch they are the folks who either
write laws or control the budget and
we're going to do in this video is dig a
little bit deeper in terms of how does
congress have oversight over the
executive branch
when we think of the executive branch we
often think of the president or maybe
the people who work around the president
but the federal bureaucracy is roughly
2.8 million people and we talk about
that in other videos and so how do we
have oversight over these 2.8 million
people well first of all there is a
whole
managerial structure within the
executive branch but on top of that you
have the legislative branch having
oversight over the executive agencies
over these 2.8 million people and
there's two primary means of this
oversight the first one is congress sets
the budget this is often known as power
of
the purse
and if congress doesn't like how a
certain agency is spending its money
they might reduce the budget there if
they really think that some agencies do
a good job or needs more resources they
might give them more resources in the
next budget
the other tool of oversight that
congress has is committee hearings
and we have talked about this in other
videos but this is where
the appropriate committee within
congress it might be within the senate
or the house of representatives will
call in leaders from the executive
agency that they are overseeing to ask
them questions hey why did this not go
as we planned or how do you deal with
this situation or why are you spending
more money than we thought you were
actually going to spend now to be clear
this is not always going to work when
we're talking about 2.8 million people
there definitely might be things that go
on within these executive agencies that
congress of course will not have
complete control of with just these two
levers or they might not even know all
of the details but they try to do the
committee hearings in order to get a
reasonable understanding of what's going
on and then leverage their budgetary
powers in order to have some level of
oversight now to get a feel for what
this looks like i'm about to show you an
example of a senate committee hearing
and this is a committee hearing where
they brought in some folks from the fbi
and what's interesting about this one
this is not about national security this
committee hearing is about relocating or
where they put the federal bureau of
investigation agency buildings and you
can see that there's definitely a tone
of oversight in this video
mr matthews i'm having a hard time
accepting what you're saying here
someone be perfectly blunt about that
you now say
a major reason for terminating the
original uh prospectus was that the
transfer of the hoover building
something that you all wanted and we
didn't want
congress didn't like that idea
but you said it was something you needed
to do to get it done
so now we're supposed to believe that's
the reason why you terminated before
something that you wanted
secondly the consolidation
one of the major reasons for the
consolidation on cost is to save rental
costs
that's what you've told us all along
that it's more expensive to have places
outside of the central location and now
you're saying it's a wash
can you understand why i'm having a hard
time accepting
the the information you're presenting
yes senator so respect to your first
question the the issue quickly because i
i heard you we have your written
statement on the transfer of the
buildings i agree with you on the
transfer of the building didn't make
sense
yes but you you insisted on it
well i would say personally i came here
in august
agency insisted on it and the
perspectives that they submitted they
insisted that this be part of the deal
yes they did and i suggest that was a
mistake
and i'd suggest that the information
you're giving us right
now may be likewise a mistake